bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur rt france racontez nous
quelle est la situation dans votre
hôpital aujourd'hui bonjour et merci de
me recevoir dans votre antenne était
notre hôpital l'hôpital le centre
hospitalier universitaire de l'hôpital
libanais j'avais tahrir au caire coeur
de beyrouth est complètement saturé tout
comme les grands centres hospitaliers de
beyrouth et du liban en général
l'occupation des lits des soins
intensifs
l' occupation des lits d'urgence de
l'occupation de toutes les unités des
soins spécialisés de l'hôpital sont
pleines les patients il faut attendre au
parking des urgences pour pouvoir
accéder aux soins mais par des fois des
passeurs paraissait à domicile nous
sommes arrivés malheureusement au
scénario auquel nous avons mis en garde
depuis plusieurs semaines le scénario
catastrophe dans lequel les soignants
ont éventuellement à choisir entre les
patients qu'il faut soigner et tout ceci
vient après une période de déconfinement
malheureusement complètement qui a
complètement échoué
d'autant plus que près de pandore pour
la période des fêtes les gens n'ont pas
du tout respecté les consignes médicales
le fêtes de noël et les fêtes du nouvel
an ont abouti à lombez decaux vide
hier nous avons atteint un nouveau
record comme vous l'avait bien dit tout
à l'heure plus de 4000 car ce qui
correspond à 40 milles cadence pour la
france parce que le liban compte pour le
dixième de la population française nous
sommes à 200 mille cas depuis le début
de l'été 2000 67000 qu'actif 1500 décès
et plus de 510 k de cas de cacqueray
très sévère et dont l'issue est
aléatoire les malades les plus graves
doit parfois doivent parfois faire le
tour des hôpitaux en espérant être
acceptée par l'un d'entre eux trouve est
indisponible ce à un prix aussi on se
tourne parfois vers les hôpitaux privés
ce n'est pas n'importe et ondes a fait
mais maintenant ce qui est encore plus
grave que même les hôpitaux privés même
des hôpitaux périphériques les hôpitaux
at au liban sont saturés des patients ne
peuvent plus
avoir accès aux soins ce qui s'amusaient
des fois c'est très difficile de pouvoir
accepter un patient vous savez aussi que
le comité est une pathologie qui dure ce
n'est pas les patients hospitalisés ne
vont pas guérir en deux jours des fois
les occupants ali pendant plusieurs
jours et des fois des semaines la
situation est catastrophique c'est un
c'est un scénario vraiment auquel on ne
voulait pas aboutir nous espérons que le
confinement cette fois ci il va aboutir
un meilleur résultat que le confinement
antérieur il faut pour cela que l'état
exige un confinement
quitte à avoir recours aux forces
militaires a mobilisé le confinement à
tout le territoire libanais sinon nous
voyons pas de notre sang nous ne nous
faisons pas d'illusions sur le scénario
futur vous dénoncez donc aujourd'hui une
incohérence dans les mesures qui ont été
décrétées par les autorités vous le
rappeliez les autorités qui ont ouvert
le pays à l'occasion des fêtes avant de
le refermer aussitôt
malheureusement je dois le dire très
drôle la politique n'a pas été sérieux
c'est vraiment ses dettes vis à vis du
combat contre la progression du coc vite
surtout il faut moderniser sur tout le
territoire libanais il faut vraiment
utiliser les moyens de dépression parce
que il y va de l'avenir de tout le pays
de toute la population
le liban sera confiné donc jusqu'à la
fin de ce mois de janvier il faudra
combien de temps selon vous avant de
pouvoir reprendre en main la situation
sanitaire
il faudra des semaines les trois
semaines décrété risque de ne pas être
suffisante
logiquement il faut quatre à six
semaines pour pouvoir voir plus clair
qui service du futur de l'évolution de
cette maladie
merci beaucoup d'avoir réagi sur notre
antenne nagy abi rached directeur
médical de l'hôpital j'étais ah oui au
liban